any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic today's
guest dr seth shawstack
of the seti institute a friend
of mine a supporter of all things
astronomical of all things
astrophysical of all things
extraterrestrial
and a great believer of the mission
of the very first finger puppet i ever
got seth you you don't have one of these
yet but this is a
a finger puppet of the late great carl
sagan
uh whose widow andruian and whose
daughter sasha sagan have honored me by
being guests
on the into the impossible podcast where
we talked to billionaires and brainiacs
and sean
seth rather you're both of course a
billionaire am i a
billionaire
that's something new i i i'm going to go
to the bank right after this
it's all that sweet sweet steady cat
well you know in all these movies
there's always some
eccentric billionaire you know lurking
behind the scenes
and you know i figure when they when
they come and sit on the seti couch
cushions
uh they might leave some some change
behind so maybe
maybe maybe not but um how are you doing
today up in northern california has the
pandemic subsided a little bit
it definitely has uh you know the
traffic has returned more or less
and people are going to restaurants
although they tend to eat outside rather
than inside but
you know it doesn't look like the day
after a nuclear war or anything anymore
yes there are some negative consequences
of the pandemic ending as you mentioned
traffic has resumed
and all sorts of things kids have gone
back to school so now they're getting
ordinary calls around here
which is uh not to be not to be savored
in any sense of the word but it is good
that life is returning to normal and i
thought we'd start today
by talking about life other life forms
this is the
uh roughly 12th anniversary of the
release of your wonderful book
confessions of an alien hunter i will
hold it up sort of here
i'll put a link to it over there in the
video uh this is a wonderful book i
listened to it i read it
everybody should listen to it and read
it multiple copies multiple times
uh this uh book actually tells kind of a
first person
memoir account not only a history of
seti and the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence uh but
from the perspective of
of you and and your life story uh kind
of taking us through what impelled you
to write that book
when you did you know as i call it the
nancy kerrigan you know problem why did
you do it now
you know or then rather what and and how
would you rewrite it if you had to re
update it for today's audience yeah
people have actually suggested that of
course those people are not going to be
tasked with having to do it but uh and
in my my experience updates seldom
are successful commercially so uh that's
an issue because this book was published
by national geographic
but the the impetus to write it when i
did
was that i was at the book fair in new
york city
and you know walking around all these
publishers
trying to pitch a book about the
long-term future of the universe there
have been many books about that since i
think that picture was okay
but i stopped at the national geographic
table and
the woman there who is now head of the
book division for national geo
she uh she liked the pitch she said but
first i want you to write a seti book
and i've said i've
i've written one which i had and she
said well i want a new one and
so that was the impetus and uh
you know it it followed after that i
mean she said
write this book and we'll give you this
percentage of
the book sales and so on and so on so it
was
indeed the publisher's impetus that
caused me to write that book
now yes carl sagan said a book is proof
that humans can work magic
because you have the voice of an author
long dead perhaps
in your mind as you're reading his or
her words now i say
as you with big picture science a
podcast is proof that
uh humans can work magic because now we
actually have literal
voices of guests and hosts such as
yourself and myself
but when we think about titles of books
we're always told not to judge a book by
its cover
and you have a very provocative
three-fingered hand uh some sort of uh
alien hand and it's not confessions of a
extraterrestrial hunter
it's confessions of an alien hunter or i
want to ask you what was the
choice of of that title driven by not
not uh
provocative as it is why not searching
for intelligence not searching for an
alien why do you consider yourself an
alien hunter
well i i think that that's again
commercial considerations i mean
in this discussion at the jacob javits
center
you know we talked about okay you want a
seti book uh you know
sort of like a confessions of an alien
hunter book and she said i like that
title
so again the the the deal here is and
you can
you know you can say that this is
lamentable that this is regrettable that
it works this way
but the idea is that if the book doesn't
have an intriguing title if it doesn't
grab you
well grab me grab somebody else then it
may just sit there on the bookshelves
and you know
one or two copies purchased by your
relatives uh
may occur but you know if you want to
bring
a return to the the publisher and you
know to yourself
uh a grabby a grabby title is a good
thing and a grabby cover is
also a good thing now that particular
cover which you mentioned with the
three-fingered
handprint that was done by one of the
designers at national
geographic and i liked it at first i
have to say it's all white it's very
you know very simple and simple is
elegant sometimes in art but
uh it was actually a very bad choice in
retrospect
because you know i was on the the car
the cold bear report at one point there
and he holds up the book to the camera
but you know being
nearly all white the cover didn't uh
didn't come across on television very
well nobody could see the three-fingered
hand and it just looked like
like a blank white book yeah that was a
mistake yeah that was simple
i am glad you changed it from your
original title my story or mineconf i'm
glad that you
you changed that that was that was a
poor choice but but i'm glad you changed
it
um so there's a lot of news i'm a
subscriber a donor i
encourage everybody to to subscribe
donate to the seti institute it's one of
my favorite
um uh causes out there in the known
multiverse
a lot of news coming out of the seti
institute including uh
janice bishop who's the recipient of the
2021 carl sagan center directors award
uh tell us about that who is janice and
what is the carl sagan
uh center director's award what does
that have to do with seti
well the institute's research has been
somewhat reorganized
when our current ceo bill diamond came
on board it used to be when i joined the
seti institute for the first time that
was
i don't know i think the civil war had
not yet broken
up uh broken out but it was about 1990
and there was only one project the seti
institute had one project and it was
seti
right and it was a nasa project so you
know it was
reasonably well funded uh to the tune of
having 40 or 50 people working on it but
then in 1993
very soon after we built the equipment
to actually do city
uh the whole program was killed by a
congressman
from nevada richard bryan was his name
he didn't know much about the science or
the project but he didn't care about
that he was interested in something that
he could
seize on to help his re-election chances
so that's what it was it was just
politics in any case
that ended that and so suddenly the seti
institute had no funding
fortunately we had a member of our board
and
actually he was involved day-to-day
operations as well barney oliver
and he knew a lot of wealthy people and
he
was able to get pledges of money from
people like bill
hewlett and david packard those were his
former bosses actually
anyhow this is becoming a long story i
didn't mean it to be a long story
but what happened was that the seti
institute
started taking on other projects besides
seti
astrobiology people who work on you know
asteroids for example these might be
important in terms of the development of
life on on a planet
and one of the big areas of study was
mars in fact if you walk down the hall
here at the seti institute
you know there are about a hundred
scientists total and uh something like
70 or 80 percent of them are studying
mars
there's now a director for all of those
that's
natalie cabral oversees all those
projects
and in order to give the people who are
basically astrobiologists
some say in the organization we
uh you know propose this director's
prize so she can give a prize to one of
these people working here and janice
bishop is somebody who's worked on
you know the the study of the clays of
mars and things like that the
composition
of the surface of mars wow fantastic
now uh also featured is a piece about
area 51
also if i believe uh correctly located
in the great state of nevada
it's interesting to note that back then
uh her uh
you know the senator who canceled the
funding for the
initial seti project that you were
describing
he was not a fan but now we have a
senator former senator harry reid
who's a huge proponent of at least maybe
ufo or uap
documentation and foia and so forth what
do you make of that turn of events from
nevada senator to nevada senator
flip-flopping so to speak
yeah well it's somewhat you could say
ironic
i mean it it's true shortly after
canceling the nasa seti project this
same
senator from nevada richard bryan went
down to
cut the ribbon as it were on the
so-called extraterrestrial
highway yes and this is the highway that
runs by
area 51 and you know the little alien
and so forth where they went to storm
area 51 and that kind of stuff
so he quickly associated himself with
the
uh ufo folk and they've
they tend to focus on nevada because of
area 51
of course and you know he was not above
encouraging
such thoughts as you know we have aliens
freeze-dried and stacked up here in
nevada
because after all it was good for the
state uh it encouraged tourism and stuff
like that
so you know it's somewhat ironic the guy
who canceled this search for the aliens
is encouraging tourists to come because
of the extraterrestrial connection
and so he indeed he indeed did that and
now
harry reid of course was the impetus
again
for this somewhat secret pentagon study
for uh you know understanding it was 22
million dollars over five years
understanding more about whether aliens
actually were visiting
earth you know sailing around our skies
and their saucers or whatever
so yeah i mean there's this you might
say it's somewhat disingenuous on the
one hand
not to support seti but on the other
hand to encourage people who want to
come to the state
because they think that's where the
aliens are right
yeah and i see the the video uh with you
uh
featured in a in a very exotic looking
setting with with very
delightful technology in the background
and then there's a stamp
uh on the seti institute youtube page
courtesy of wikipedia of our friends at
wikipedia describing the context behind
area 51 lest anybody get the wrong idea
about taking certain scientific or maybe
uh non-scientific uh pieces of
information
out of context so we have youtube now
telling and now probably this video will
get
stamped and and earmarked etc what do
you make of of the
kind of attention that outside the
tension that ufos are getting nowadays
uh in uh had a conversation with mick
west on the podcast generated
tremendous attention i'm hopefully gonna
have at least one of the pilots maybe
two of the pilots involved
in the famous nimitz encounter the tic
tac encounter uh that have been in the
news on 60 minutes
uh and so forth the subject of the marco
rubio and other
investigations um what do you make of
this attention and then sort of the
possibility that it's it's being used
maybe not for nefarious
purposes seth but maybe to sort of um
you know agitate for more military
budget or more
seti budget even what do you think about
these uh
extra scientific purposes that these
releases are perhaps being used for
well i don't know that they are being
used to i mean who do you support
if if you believe and one-third of
americans do believe this
that we're being visited that they're
alien craft you know sailing through our
airspace
um you know what how does that affect
what you do
in terms of your political choices
there's been this idea of
disclosure that has come to completely
dominate
the ufo community in my experience that
is
you know 10 years ago if you were one of
those
one in three americans 100 million
americans who think that
dog on it there's something to this ufo
stuff some of these craft are
extraterrestrial visitors you would
argue
on the basis of you know particular
events
maybe the ones in britain at the
randallstoom forest
maybe roswell i mean roswell is kind of
the poster child for all this
you know every year there are more
sightings there like 10 000 sightings
per year so you you would advocate for
this
but it might not affect the the defense
budget
now you have these videos that the navy
pilots have made with their infrared
gunsight cameras
and they've stirred up a lot of
excitement in the ufo community because
it looks like their hope for disclosure
that the government is going to weigh in
and say
actually some of these sightings are of
extraterrestrial craft
that's what they're waiting for and
because of a in addition
to the uh budget of 1.3
billion dollars that was passed in
december
part of that bill includes a
requirement that the intelligence
agencies and particularly the office of
naval intelligence
come clean write a report drop it on the
desks of congress people
by the end of this month so everybody's
excited and i think that this is
going to pose a very interesting uh
scenario i think we're going to see
something very interesting in the sense
that
i've written an article for nbc about
what i expect is going to happen
and what i expect is going to happen is
that this is the same thing that
happened
when we got reports of project blue book
project grudge project sign
all these investigations into putative
alien spacecraft always come back
with well eighty percent of them ninety
percent of them we can explain as
prosaic phenomena
lagoons aircraft whatever ten percent we
can't
and i think that's what's going to
happen here and i i think the
consequences of the
of that the sequelae of that are going
to be kind of
interesting because suddenly this idea
that
will prove the existence of ufos by
disclosure is going to be shown
to not work right yeah oftentimes i find
that you know
the coda to many of these stories by the
ufos are
alien technology techno signatures uh
you know some of the proof that they are
is that no
wreckage of the craft was found you know
near the site of the reported incident
and i always say you know my daughter
will say something like you know there's
a unicorn here
last night and um it was interacting
with me
and you know they're invisible and but
you know so there's no unicorn
scat was found near the site of her
visitor
the previous night i tried to explain to
her you know that's not you know lack of
evidence is not evidence of lack
uh or there maybe perhaps the other way
around but
um but i want to tie that into you know
the famous the famous
namesake of a lot of what's done in in
seti which is
which is frank drake and he just
celebrated a birthday recently
according to the newsletter uh a
milestone birthday
and that is uh that is his eponymous
equation
the drake equation i believe is 60 years
old now
is that not correct yeah no that is
correct it was
formulated 19 formulated no no pun
intended it was formulated in 1961
indeed and it was the agenda for a
meeting now
if you look at the uh the drake equation
i always say and i love frank as much as
anybody uh but if i got an equation like
that and i got a result handed in by
some of my undergraduates
the equation you know states and you'll
go through it perhaps uh some of the
terms that most
apply to the research that you conduct
but if i got a number and it was turned
in without an uncertainty
or an error estimation i would perhaps
return that with a big red
f on top of the student's grade because
no number in science is meaningful
without an error associated with it
and i when i spoke when i was honored to
speak and you hosted me at the seti
institute in 2016
and i'll put a link here or maybe there
maybe here
to that talk because it was so enjoyable
that
that discussion i did i said well let's
estimate the number of people at the san
diego zoo right now because one of the
hypotheses the answers to the fermi
paradox
why they're not here is that just as my
kids don't bang on the cage of the
gorilla exhibit here
they don't make their presence known so
let's do an example calculation how many
people are in the san diego zoo right
now
and i estimate like 8 000 but my errors
because i'm not that great a scientist
or about plus or minus eight thousand uh
so no number is meaningful without the
error bars and i wonder what's your take
on
on drake's equation i mean has anyone
done a sophisticated enough analysis i
see things like there are 36
civilizations in the galaxy
but then there's no error bar associated
with it so to what extent can we sign
my audience is very erudite i've had
nine nobel prize winners on the show
uh future noble list speaking to now uh
dr seth shawstak uh seth tell us what is
what is the issue what what what kind of
um from an expert's perspective
what do you think about the drake
equation is is it just kind of like a
back of the envelope what can we do with
it
yeah by the way should i book my flight
to stockholm i mean i have okay
i have some good news for i have a
medallion here somewhere for you
yeah that's indeed well look the drake
equation indeed
was motivated uh simply by this meeting
that was being held
in 1961 because frank drake the year
before
done the first modern study experiment
and it generated a lot of interest it
was in collier's magazines over and over
which was a big deal
at the time so the public was very
interested he got
about a dozen people to attend these
were all
you know established scientists bright
people carl sagan was among them
although he wasn't as well known back in
1961 as he would later become
but it was an agenda item
well as the agenda i should say for this
meeting he devised this
great equation and it was actually
somewhat similar to
an equation that harlow shapley a
well-known astronomer
had devised earlier for other purposes
but it was the same
sort of thing where you trying to find n
and in this case being the number of
civilizations
who are broadcasting signals that we
could pick up
okay and obviously that depends on how
many civilizations are out there and
that's determined by the number of stars
that have planets that can support
life what fraction of them ever do cook
up life and what fraction of those
ever get to the stage of being able to
build a radio transmitter so there are
six
parameters in this equation now you
could say well that sounds great
what what's the answer you know how many
societies are out there
and the answer to that question is we
don't know the answer to that question
uh do we know it any better than he knew
the param the values of the parameters
back in 1961
in general not the only parameter we
know better
than we did then is the fraction of
stars that have planets
uh that's that's essentially all stars
you know but that was what they assumed
at the time
so the estimates that come out of this
could be one there's one society in the
uh
in the galaxy that is uh clever and
that's us
or you know a hundred million that's
another possibility
and all these things uh fall within the
error bars because the air bars are
essentially
infinite because we only have a sample
of one to
to analyze right and when i think about
that you know kind of large-scale
uncertainties and applied
you know throughout the throughout the
visible uh
throughout the galaxy and some even
apply it throughout the universe which i
think is even more
perilous in application nevertheless i
think it is kind of a tool useful tool
to apply
uh and i want to segue from from drake
to a question i've asked you know at
least three of the nobel prize winners
that have been on the show ray weiss
barry barish um
and john mather and that has to do with
those are all experimentalists that have
been on the show
and that has to do with you know how to
when when to pull the plug
and um and and it has to do with with
experiments that are long duration
possibly high risk possibly high reward
but certainly all experiments cost money
and i think it's a fair question to ask
and i asked it of these three noble
lists
when do you decide to stop an experiment
and and by what criteria
do do you decide to do that to
decommission something so we have to
think about that whenever we build
an instrument on foreign soil because we
don't own the
the territory in chile or in even in
hawaii or at the south pole we have to
think about decommissioning
we have to be stewards of the land or
whatever uh but i want to ask you
you know bigger picture when when
it would be what would be the the
bayesian criteria
by which you would say okay we've we've
done it you're famous for making your
coffee bets
okay those are great seth but but you
know pretty low stakes
when would you say okay it's enough we
can stop looking for seti or
is there no criterion to do it well i
don't think yeah
yeah if we were doing the same
experiment that frank drake did in 1960
uh you know i'm sure that we would say
okay we're going to stop this because we
haven't found anything
i mean it's been 60 years since the
first modern study experience 60 years
is a long time to run an experiment
i'm hard pressed to think of any
experiment that's been run that long
actually
and there's no guarantee that in the
next 60 years we'll
we'll find anything so you might say
well let's stop it and indeed that's one
criterion for stopping it if you
don't have any money to keep doing the
experiment then you will stop it
so in a sense your hand is forced but
there's there's a you know a kind of
another there's another factor here that
i think is extremely important
and that is the seti experiments keep
getting better that's because they're
mostly dependent on computer power
and everybody knows that compute power
keeps going up it follows
moore's law whatever doubles every 18
months on average and that kind of thing
so that means that whatever experiment
you're doing now normally has a
you know gathers as much data as all the
previous experiments but together
right whatever you've done the last two
years is the sum
total of seti in some way uh not
entirely true but
largely true and as long as the
experiments getting faster and faster
and faster
there's no clear point at which you say
forget it and you could say oh well look
by what date will we have examined all
300 or whatever it is
billion stars in the milky way galaxy
you know looking for signals coming from
from those planetary systems they have
and uh
that isn't so far away if things keep
improving exponentially as they are
doing
uh so that would be a natural end but
you know even then i don't think we
would stop because
the conclusion you would make by
stopping
is to say or come to is that there's
nobody out there you can't find any
signals because
you know we're the smartest things in
the galaxy something that
most of my neighbors seem to believe now
that could be
it doesn't seem very reasonable so i
don't know that there's any clear-cut
end to this
now uh there's an old joke uh i'm just
going to read it because if i try to
remember it it won't be very funny
uh but uh so there's a joke about
archaeologists in france
they were digging they dug down to a
depth of a thousand meters they found
traces of copper wire
and it was a thousand years old and they
came to the conclusion that their
ancestors in france
had a telephone network that existed a
thousand years ago
now the french uh you know didn't want
to you know
have lay claim to this ancient
technology so the british were famously
you know quite quite obstinate about it
and they said no we went to 2000 meters
and we went all the way down and we
found actually a fiber optic glass cable
and they said we actually had higher
advanced technology that's even
older than your copper technology and
then
a thousand years a thousand meters
deeper than that
the germans dug deeper and they found
nothing
and the conclusion was they invented
wi-fi
so you know my question is by what you
know right do we have to expect that
alien civilizations will be broadcasting
using any
resources that we could possibly detect
in
other words you know perhaps they're not
even going to waste their time or they
would have gone to
you know fiber optics or something and
they'll never be a signal that we could
detect so
you know is the is the the search for
optical steady like my colleague
upstairs shelly wright who you know um
or or even the the uh
looking for radio signals is that
possibly you know kind of thinking
of the past that around the milieu of
which said he developed in the
radar and and also telecommunications
are is that just
a byproduct of that mode of thinking and
now maybe we have to think in some other
mode of thinking techno signatures or
something different
yeah well i can assure you i get emails
at least
well i get emails every day about this
subject but every two weeks or so
i get an email saying oh you guys are
using radio that's
pretty uh pretty old school that's
really archaic i mean they're not going
to be using radio
well maybe they aren't i mean there's
certainly historic precedent for that
point of view 150 years ago there were
proposals for
uh seti experiments to you know let the
martians in on our existence
and they you look back at them and you
say well they're very quaint
right they would never work for a host
of good reasons but
and maybe that'll be true of what we're
doing now but all you can do
is the best you can do i mean all you
can do is say
you know the the best thinking in
astronomy and technology and all that
sort of thing
and do that experiment because you can't
do anything else people say why aren't
you looking for
subspace communication which is what
they use on star trek
and that's great it works on star trek
but you know nobody knows if you go to
the stanford bookstore and
i'd like to get a textbook on some space
communication please
and you know they'll usher you out of
the store so
it's it's uh you know you have to go
with what you have
you could say they're not going to use
radio technology or lasers or any of
that stuff maybe not
but i would bet that they do not for the
same reasons we use this stuff
these are just good technologies based
on you know fundamental physics
to get bits of information from one
place to another
and whether those bits of information
are reality television with klingons or
whether it's something else
they will be using it it's like the
wheel was invented a long time ago
and we still use it and we will probably
always use it right
even though it's very old technical
wheels so so old school
why don't you do something else to put
on the bottom of your your vehicles
there
so i you know that's the argument i
would make that we're using
essentially fundamental physics uh as
the basis for
for the experiment and of course uh
and you have a deep background dating
back to your
years at princeton and your connection
to my grand advisor
david wilkinson who's my phd advisor's
phd advisor
long ago when you were an undergraduate
at princeton if i recall correctly
um and you played a prank on him or he
played a prank on you is that right i
seem to recall you telling uh an
anecdote about you
uh playing a prank on david wilkinson do
you remember that story
i do well i remember a story this may
not be
the story but yeah yeah i was one of
well i think i was dave wilson
wilkinson's first
student if you will but anyhow and he
had lots of good advice
about marriage and all sorts of topics
which
which i actually quite valued then and
still but in any case
uh i was doing a lab experiment in a
physics building and
with my with my lab partner rudy tune
who
later on became a physicist at the
university of michigan anyhow
we went to the window because we heard
some noise outside and down there in the
parking lot was dave wilkinson with a
couple other people and they have this
cart with some sort of apparatus on it
that clearly
was looking up at the sky it had a
little microwave horn
aimed at the sky we didn't know what it
was about turns out he was looking for
the three degree background radiation
you know the leftover
glow if you will the big bang but we
didn't know any of that
we just saw that he had some sort of
equipment that looked like it was some
sort of receiver
so we just wheeled over a microwave
transmitter that we were using for our
experiment to the window we aimed it
down at
his apparatus and i tapped out on the
power supply in morse code
what half god wrought which was samuel
moore's first
telegraph signal between washington and
baltimore as i recall anyhow
and you know then we've went back to
what
whatever we were doing now we never
heard from wilkinson about this but then
later you know the nobel prize was given
to the people who actually did find the
three degree background radiation
and he became involved in all that and i
i thought cheapest creepers maybe we
you know caused uh something terrible to
happen here that was a bank
i later quizzed him about that he just
left yeah you could have uh cost him a
trip to stockholm south that that
is that you should never yeah you're a
merry prankster but uh we should all
have our limits
um one thing that i love about
confessions of an alien hunter
especially rereading it again in
preparation for this interview
was you know how prescient you were
thinking about the you know kinds of
of different arguments that people make
for you know why aliens why ufos are
real and why they're coming now
uh but also why scientists such as
yourself myself
shelly wright upstairs here at uc san
diego why
scientists would be the most excited uh
you know if
they're actually true because we would
have a chance to shortcut
perhaps you know centuries of learning
about physics and making mistakes and
wrong turns and learning about uh
incorrect theories and
so forth we would have a shortcut a hack
and so no one would be more invested and
talk about instant shortcut to grants uh
you know success and
and tenure but actually we're most often
as as you know in the book
accused of being you know kind of uh
seth uh
seth not sanguine or you know kind of
seth downer
talk about those experiences the the the
kind of missives that you get
that accuse you of being anti-alien or
anti you know van alien hunter
you should be more sanguine about about
detecting aliens but you're not so
what's what's between all that well i'm
certainly saying about detecting aliens
but not by looking up at the sky and
seeing them sail across
the vastness of the night sky it no
uh most of the criticism indeed comes
from people who are convinced
that the evidence for visitors is very
good and the the fact that i'm a skeptic
on that
and so you know there are two points
here one is that
this is a very emotional issue these
people will say things to me that they
would
that nobody at a cocktail party would
ever say to me
it just isn't polite you know it's ad
hominem attacks and stuff like that
but they get you know some of them are
actually kind of interesting because
they say okay
you know we're being visited but you
can't say it because your job depends on
you not
saying it up in sinclair right yeah yeah
you that's right you can't blow the
whistle on this stuff um
that's amusing because of course there's
no restriction on what you
want to say about any of this stuff but
anyhow so they're those but others where
they
say okay you can stop playing around now
we have
conclusive proof look at these tick-tock
videos and uh
tic tac videos the tic toc videos are
better look at these tic tac
videos and uh you know you can see for
yourself that this is
not this is not some earthly craft here
this is something else
that's a tremendous extrapolation from
what they see to what they think it is
but in any case and that leads and i say
well i don't really think so because
consider this situation
and that would explain the video and it
doesn't involve aliens right and
then then they usually get angry but i
do answer all the emails i do answer
them yeah
yeah you're noted for your uh polite
penmanship and your
intimately prose another thing you talk
about is sort of the physics behind all
this which i find fascinating to
speculate on as all
science fiction nerds and i'm the
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination arthur c
clarke
knew a thing or two about speculation
about the future and i'm going to ask
you
some what i call my thrilling three
questions that i ask all my guests
at the end of each episode seth in just
a moment but um you know one thing that
that he would always you know kind of
talk about is that you know any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and you
know michael shermer who i
know that you know talks about that any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from aliens and
sort of that you can kind of
um you know append on almost any any
phenomena and you can associate it with
anything
advanced as long as you say physics
beyond the standard model and
i had on recently michio kaku as i know
you have
and then i've had on avi loeb who i
don't know if you've had on but you know
these are people working at the
forefront of physics you know one in and
string theory one
opposed to string theory they both
believe in extraterrestrial existence of
extraterrestrials one believes we've
been visited
by techno signature from an alien
civilization
uh the other believes that we will
someday you know become avatars riding
on interstellar light beams
and so these are serious scientists
right so
uh if they're in the mainstream
believing it you know it kind of takes
courage to to sort of stand opposed in
that
to say that no we're actually there's
less evidence for it
in fact when yes your job in some sense
depends on searching for it so i do just
want to salute you for
for having that courage and and and
standing up as you do
so steadfastly talk about just in the
remaining minutes before i go into the
final questions and we break for our
live stream conversation
talk about big picture science what kind
of things are you excited about projects
that you're working on at the seti
institute that our listeners should know
about
well big picture science which is our
weekly radio show and podcast
uh takes on all areas of science it's
not restricted to the
kind of science done in the halls here
behind me uh so
indeed we've we've talked about a lot
about the animal behavior that's always
interesting
plants things like that we try and talk
about something
where there's been some recent
development that makes it interesting
um or we also do once a month with
something called skeptic check where we
do sort of a skeptical show
and you know obvious topics would be
indeed these navy videos
but we've done there was a big bigfoot
press conference
about 15 years ago that we covered we we
went to the press conference and
interviewed the people presenting there
they they claimed to have found a
bigfoot body in northern georgia okay i
don't know what bigfoot was doing down
there you know maybe
looking for pralines i'm not sure but in
any case
you know so that sort of thing and we
typically
you know interview three or four people
every week
uh it keeps the show lively that kind of
thing and it's actually the show's
recorded in this room that i'm sitting
in i'm in the studio now and you can't
see much
because the walls are all lined with
black acoustic foam
so it's not very interesting to look at
but in any case yeah it's you know
it's it's hard work people probably
don't realize that because they just
hear the final product and
the final product is you know relatively
smooth but of course what goes into it
is not at all smooth so
and it's hard to do during the covid
pandemic i have to say because we can't
tell people to
go to their local radio station where we
can set up an electronic connection
that has very high audio quality and
that's something we always did but
now we have to do it at home with you
know with the help of zoom well
in fact i think we don't actually use
them for the uh
for the show but anyhow that's a that's
a technical matter the idea is that the
show can cover
all areas of science not just the
science done at the seti institute yeah
yeah it is uh it is uh one of my
favorite podcasts i listen to it uh
religiously
and uh skeptically too so now seth we
have come to the final three which i
call the thrilling three questions which
i ask all my guests and i've had guests
such as jill tarter
and i hope to uh and i hope to have many
many
more guests from the seti institute from
other places around
the multiverse and i'm going to ask you
questions two of which go into the deep
future
yours personally humanities generally
and then we're going to go into the past
and they kind of revolve around arthur c
clarke in some way or another but the
first one has to do with
your future so uh it involves you
when you leave this mortal coil at the
biblical age
of 120 years old i want to ask you seth
as i ask everybody what do you want to
leave in your ethical will not your
material will i know that's mostly going
to go to me
and other material fungible support for
me but uh but
what do you want to leave in your
ethical will what wisdom have you
accrued that you want to leave to your
ideological errors
on planet earth well that's a good
question for which i don't have a good
answer
i'm not sure what i've done one tends to
look back on their
career at some point and say well uh you
know what's the most important thing i
did and i've done some things that i
thought were relatively
uh not important but at least you know
might still be remembered 50 years from
now 200 years now i'm sure nothing will
be remembered
but it's you know the idea that science
can be interesting
uh that that first struck me in uh
in seventh grade actually i was sitting
in our science class along with
everybody else's
our teacher mr chappiewski began to you
know kept lecturing about something
and the material was actually
interesting i mean what he was
talking about was interesting but the
way he was talking about it was not
interesting and you all you had to do is
look around at the class
and you could see that you know these
seventh grade students were not
really so interested and i kept thinking
to myself why can't he make this
interesting
right so you know i always try and
i've always tried to make my lectures
interesting
and and articles i write a lot of
articles so uh
yeah yeah i think that that may be the
legacy uh arthur c clarke had some
fundamental new ideas i don't know that
i've had any of those
but at least his writings were
interesting yeah
you've done wonderful work we've been
together on a couple of occasions i
always treasure being with you in person
we were last together with alex
philippenko about two years ago
uh at an event about the nobel prize and
accelerating universe
that was really fun and alex is uh as
another treasured colleague and friend i
hope we have him on the show at some
point too
next question this now goes deep into
the future
based on the sentinel and arthur c
clarke's 2001 space
odyssey has to do with a monolith this
ominous
feature that makes an appearance
throughout the movie and and so forth
that's sort of a time capsule
sort of meant to represent a warning or
or perhaps it's a time capsule or
whatever we don't know what it really is
uh but it could be like richard feynman
said you know this
this this way to encapsulate in the
cataclysm
the most dense amount of human
information in the shortest
briefest amount of bits possible i want
to ask you if you had a monolith
to last for a billion years like the
2001 space odyssey
what would you put on it or in it to
encapsulate everything human beings had
done
or learned yeah well this question comes
up
in connection with broadcasting into
space
called metis sometimes messaging
extraterrestrial intelligence
and you know we've done a lot of that
actually no matter what you think of
whether it's a good thing to do or a
dangerous thing to do whatever
uh you know we've sent little greeting
cards into space that
pioneer plaques on the pioneer
spacecraft and the voyager record and
yeah you know
uh and some deliberate transmissions
actually to the sky too but most of what
we're sending in this space are
the inadvertent transmissions like radar
and
fm radio and television they all go into
space that's right
and i my only thought here is that
we've tended to think of these messages
as being greeting cards we sent a couple
of thousand bits into space and
trying to decide well should we put in
beethoven or should we put in the
beatles
that kind of thing i i would because you
can get now
all the text of the library of congress
onto a thumb drive
i would send lots and lots of
information because i think that makes
it easier on the aliens
because they can decode it a lot more
quickly if you send them a lot of
material
yeah and also you know it's not biased i
mean you could just send the internet
i suppose the aliens would figure we'd
look like cats but you know you could do
it
indeed yeah i asked that question of
andrewian and she said oh i already did
that you know i put
carl put my brain waves on on the
voyager golden disc
so that was pretty cool to actually have
someone who
did that before and they said that would
last for a billion years
uh last question seth now going
backwards in time for some advice
to your former self and it involves sir
arthur c clarke's third law
which states the only way of discovering
the limits of the possible
is to go beyond them into the impossible
and that's the origin of this podcast
lovely name i want to ask you seth what
mysterious
aspect of life perplexed you as a 20
year old
about 10 years ago but now makes sense
uh because
uh you had the courage to go into the
impossible in other words what advice
would you give
to a younger seth shostak
i don't know uh listen to your mom i
don't know i i think
i would give them that advice actually
but
i think that i would also say don't
listen to your dad uh
not because you shouldn't listen to your
dad but my dad had you know
ideas about what his kids should pursue
as careers
and you know it wasn't that they were
bad they were all well motivated
and in the end uh actually came came to
fruition
but the advice i would give anybody
young not just me but
you know is pay attention to those
things you're interested in somewhere
between the ages of 8 and 11 i think
kids get interested in something and
those
interests whatever they are are
interests that they keep forever
and those don't go away those are very
fundamental and you know i think that's
just evolution speaking but whatever
is the reason for it i would be sure
that you
don't give in to the external pressures
that you will surely get
to switch your interest to something
that has either better job prospects or
you know allows your parents to say my
son the doctor or whatever
you know follow your interest because
you'll do better at it
and uh you'll be happier that's such
great advice seth i
i always say you know and you are a
doctor by the way uh yeah
not the kind that helps people although
you do prescribe certain medica no i'm
just kidding
uh but but i always say yeah i mean
curios you know people say oh follow
your passion is bad
but it is good advice you know curiosity
is is sustains you passion is the spark
that ignites the curiosity that's the
fuel
and and look where it took us i you know
i think it's i think it's wonderful seth
uh you're an inspiration you're such a
cheerful good-natured ambassador i
i i do you know it's it's not good good
policy you think about like um apple
doesn't endorse
google phones right like i'm endorsing
your podcast it means
people aren't gonna listen to my podcast
they're listening here but anyway it's a
zero-sum game but i love your
i love your work i love the seti
institute please give to it please
support it
and um and i i love it so much i do it
myself
so thank you for being a friend and a
supporter and and just a goodwill
ambassador to the universe
thank you brian it's really been a
pleasure any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you